What talk about
ising of interactive Communication
and Second
Tutorial Mod for Unique
de
First
Ling
of
interactive And The Second Part Will Be
Unique
decoding First What let me Just give A
Quick Reminder What is list decoding in
One Way setting have Alice
chel
SS
S But Will  assume is More One Half of
errors This Channel in This Way is no
Chance
recover
People Person Says So what We Are to do
IDE of
decoding What Bob doing Just output
Small list of answers and
hopefully
Alice
and
Speaking
mayn
isrt
ofr
TR to TR Come Out  Of
protocol
so is General IDE
of decoding of interactive Communication
andas very
Natural First Reason of course Because
allows US to Deal
much
US per efficient
effing
efficient Unique
decoding
aud Unique
decoding uning more
details
As many
times Complete problem
for interactive Communication is Pointer
Jumping  problem Pointer Chasing problem
or any other ideas and What This problem
is problem is the following we have
binary and Alice is
given
Set of edges given subs of edges
on layers
and Bob given subset of edges on even
layers Go From to
Le so This is and  This problem
essentially We Are going to solve with
list decoding so
our Task in some Sense will be
to Will Get Alice and Bob gets instance
of Pointer Jumping problem and the Goal
is to output
Small Small Set of possible leaves such
that The correct leaf Will Be  in This
Set
Freem
Exist
protocol
ADV
Si Communication complexity
of It Only
constant only constant overhead
in
I will not be able to Give today
proof Because don't have enough Time But
I will Try to give
you
IDE
Fail
probabilistic But protocol
doesn't such
protocol No
assumption
Alice What We
to
use
bern
eff
R
OK
is aare any
Si siz like How well It's Pretty easy to
show that One Over EPS Is kind optimal
So Order of optimal And you can achieve
it And I don't know like if you  can like
proba If you go to some expon canu
Communication
But aware of
The
Main Run into trying to
Pro trying to
Main Think
about and Bob has Two possible Messages
that Alice told to
Him so in some Sense Bob has to Answer
to both of These Messages  so he needs to
Send Back to
Alice Answer for each one of This for
each one of This Messages so He needs to
Send Answer for this and Answer for
this But When we The Code each of these
answers Now We Get already four possible
possibilities
Fast Will  A Over
Si to
solve
Us and try communs are to
ses in our Pointer
Jumping so Al Alice Will going to Send
First Age When Bob
Will L The Code and Get say Two
possibilities When he is going to Send
list of Two edes Set of edes not  to
ses independently
communs
ife
Get Dee
LS for each
Set
Unique
find
assume
assum This
and and Another
Age AG again is Unique Age He to
continue
protocol
anding
Set so This Way will be able to manage
our protocol not Burst Out
so
for
alphabet Si Very Very  huge
butting reduce alphabet size so First
Idea how to reduce alphabet size
From polynomial
in From exponential in depth T to
polynomial in essentially Same Idea and
in Order to reduce alphabet size to
constant like requires much More Work in
Unique decoding because
Yes
alphabet
Get
Si
will
Basic
All
hows
Way
L
dec and S Back to
Alice not going to tell you What exact
properties of list Rec But One of
Property May
Mind
me
pereh
Yes Set of
consistent and for
any is no Two edges Going Out so it
should be correct layers and  ises Going
out of the
node B recover
UN able to
recover be able to recover One of
possible
sets so and for each of such Set which
Will Be of size L Times What We expect
to be he respon Only one
Edge is it Clear So if anyone  have
questions like How We prevent From
blowing Up It's a good time to Ask
even Better like consider
not This is is General Idea of
list L decoding
and the Hard Part essentially Here is to
define
correctly list Rec in a Way that on One
Hand it Will  Exist and Another it Will
Be
useful so Because like trivial
generalization of ces to decoding
settings possible to show does Exist
OK
so Now let me swit to
Another Topic Now let me go to Unique
decoding
and
AS
details How you do it But could you tell
US  You Know Why The like The First
Thing it Will
take Now Let's so As already
discussed there is upper B amount of
Noise that We are able to handle is of One
Quarter If we have a fixed Order of
Speaking and Two sev If we have not Non
fixed Order of Speaking But Let's Try to
Rec Why was This bounds are tight and if
you look Why Bounce tight the reason is
the following Because adversary Alice
Bob adversary Just Pick One of parties
He could like depending What our
protocol is He Pick One of parties  and
concentrate all his effort on This Party
and by doing This he be able he be
Always able
to ruin Out our
conversation and This is the reason Why
One Quarter or Two
S But Now Let's consider Another Mod of
No and Let assume allow Here at Alpha
fraction of Noise and Here at Better
fraction of
Noise so Now We not allow adversary to
concentrate all his effort on One of the
parties so We Are saying OK you
can corrupt
Here
0.49 and Here say
0.1 can We Still be able to decode
for
PA a
anding
Answer Strange region for
possible What was known before it
If If Alpha From If alp Plus Bet less
than One Quarter When It's Unique
decoding is possible and there is like
some very Strange
region it's not smoo It's Continuous But
it's not Smooth for which Unique
decoding  is
possible and i to convince you that ess
our decoding algorithm
Let's Try to do The Most trivial so we
have a decoding algorithm When we
Exchange edges and by the end We Need to
output list of possible answers But Just
One Answer so The Best Thing  to do
in Cas Just
output
algor algor for
Long end algor output Most PL
Answer Now What I CLA i claim the
following
If
Yes adversarial so When you say Most PL
possible I mean Is there Under What
probability ah it's not probabilities
Just Under hing
distance  Most PL Answer it means Under
So what we have we have interaction
so we have Here
some So what we have we have some tre
Code Right so there is some tre Code
and We know that
Pass
ine
and
oned
takee
Andr
If
a
Most
correct One
for
If So what We need So if need both of
the parties Will output correct Answer
Will need alp
Plus 2 Bet L 1 - EPS
and
a Let
assume
contradiction and He sends to
Alice some Messages
and so and Alice and Bob Send
Inc hise so is  correct message Bob S
along correct
One
Cor
Out
output clos
cod possible
to clos
possible
Because thise has properties ofe We know
that distance between This Two Words is
almost One Min
EPS distance between This and This is 1
Min
EPS so it means at this period  of
Time at this period of Time adversary
corrupted in Order Will Be more
Time
of
edes
Here Alice will always be able to get to
the correct node Because by adding
anything Outside of edes As Long As Main
consistent there is no way you can mess
Up correct
Solution so This is Idea We Need somehow
to
get Once Once I Send you
What My correct
edges is no
way
IDE
decoding Talking More
does What Does It me means
Time
able at this Point Alpha Plus Beta must
be greater than 1 -
EPS and so by  Looking on This precisely
It's like Better The Best Thing that
adversary can do is to corrupt first
Alpha fraction of coordinates of Alice
and then Half of the coordinates of
Bob This is the best Thing that
adversary can do Okay and This Way
Bet
From looks We
aler  Bound alp If greater alp Bet ADV
can always mess Up let me Give
andes
Wrong
in
Order
Communication
Communication Take First FR
Will Just One Communication Bob Alice
Because assume assume our Communication
not exponential linear
or Sub exponential Will by This Point of
Time Because there is  no Communication
From Alice Will Be at least Two
possibilities Two different
possibilities Bob correct and Bob Non
correct
possibili
fores The
Answer and Now What ADV Will do Just
corrupt Half of Bob correct so that Will
Get so that Bob Non correct Will Be Most
PL Answer so  Because by This time
adversary can
SP spend One Half of
errors so This is this amount of time
is
alp Because assume alp Plus
Great
Great greater Bet
Here More One
Budget any
Fails
can
Only
happen
speaks speaks FR communic Bob
spoke FR
communic
mesice so it happen  Try to corrupt first
Alpha fraction of Communication of Alice
by Time Bob sends Only like say alp
dived by 10 of his
Communication and If This is the Case
Here Will not Get Half of the
Error and essentially This
is Fails
andal is
for alp Bet
Best can
even of If One
Part
correctly
will
alp
so by aning and showing is tight We Can
ess
Show correct
reges mathematical Formula But to do
it
so Here One can Make Another objection
for this Model of Noise and say OK so
the reason Why We are not able to  decode is
Because like We Try to prevent From
Alice and Bob to
communicate in fact essentially If We do
allow for Bob to communicate So if
Exchange
CH Alice Bob
Alice and Bob
exch Messages and
ADV corrupt both of
Messages
any of CH able to tole all the way  Up
fraction of in Case
of All Way up
ine
all
Le decoding if you have
questions The
Next
If
Bob Once Bob What
is correct of Alice
Always
Always Send his correct
messes
correct his Set and by continue
Communication He Just adds his
correct So You can corrupt  Communication
But can corrupt your
mind Add other
edges
V
Pass